Hey guys, this Joel. And I wanted to do another kind of follow up to the Psychohistory of American Psychology series for a while. Just because something really funny happened that sort of proved the thesis of the whole thing right, right after I did it. And a lot of people noticed and they actually sent me the article, the FDA study. So I thought that was really funny that you guys were on. that and saw immediately how, because I, every time I do one of these, I get a million emails from people that are like, you're good evidence-based practice. Why do you not like science? This is the reason that those things are there. You said placebo effect, but this is the reason that that's there. And you said impact factor, but these are the reason that we do it. And I'm like,
大家好，我是Joel。我想针对《美国心理学的心理历史》系列做一个后续补充，因为就在我做完那个系列后，发生了一件非常有趣的事，它在某种程度上证明了我的整个论点。很多人注意到了这一点，并把那篇关于FDA研究的文章发给了我。我觉得你们能注意到这一点并立刻看出其中的门道，这真的很有趣。因为每次我做这类节目，都会收到成千上万封邮件，人们会说：“你这是在反对循证实践，你为什么不喜欢科学？”这就是为什么那些东西会存在的原因。你说那是安慰剂效应，但这就是它存在的原因；你说那是影响因子，但这就是我们这么做的原因。而我只想说，
no, no, no, I've done it. I've done it for a long time. Like, I know why we do it. What I'm saying is that doing it does not point you back to knowledge of something. It's just a thing that you are doing. I know how it works. What I'm saying is that understanding how it works does not mean that you're getting any information out of it that is useful. And they will just keep telling you, but this is the way the system works. If you're criticizing, you must not understand. And there's like no ability that they have to be like, oh, you know how it, you know how it works. You don't need more information about that.
不，不，不，我做过这些研究，而且做了很长时间。我知道我们为什么要这么做。我想说的是，这样做并不能让你真正获得某种知识，这仅仅是你正在做的一件事。我知道它是如何运作的，但我想说的是，理解它如何运作并不意味着你能从中获得任何有用的信息。他们只会不断地告诉你：“这就是系统的运作方式，如果你在批评，那一定是你没理解。”他们根本没有能力去想：“哦，你既然知道它是如何运作的，那就不需要更多关于这方面的信息了。”
You just don't like it. Like, that's not an option. And so anyway, I get a million emails from like that from people that stumble on the podcast and listen to one episode and then don't listen. anymore or the blog or whatever. And so because the FDA did this 24 MDMA study, right after the psycho history series came out and it had been out for a while, but it got into the press and it got like people were kind of looking at it. A lot of people were like, oh my God, this is exactly what you just said in Senate. And I thought that was really funny. So the people did make that connection in a positive way, was funny. And then I also wanted to do something about kind of the
你只是不喜欢它，这在他们看来是不可能的。总之，我收到了成千上万封来自那些偶然发现这个播客、听了一集就不再听了，或者不再看博客的人的邮件。因为在《心理历史》系列播出后，FDA进行了这项MDMA研究，虽然它已经发布了一段时间，但当它进入媒体视野并引起人们关注时，很多人说：“天哪，这和你刚才说的完全一样。”我觉得这很有趣。所以，人们能以积极的方式建立这种联系，这很有意思。然后，我还想谈谈关于
economy and oil because I wanted to be like I'm not just picking on on psychology what I'm was saying with the psycho history series is the micro is the macro the same way that you can psychoanalyze a nation or an empire you can also psychoanalyze the people that make it up like it's the same functions they deflect in the same way like every bureaucracy behaves just like the bureaucracy in an individual's head and and then I saw Christopher Nolan's the Odyssey and it was sitting with some themes in that and I was like oh man which one should I do next and then they all kind of came together in my head and I was like, well, I don't know. If I do this quickly, maybe they, because they are all kind of the same thing or touching
经济和石油的话题，因为我想表明我不仅仅是在针对心理学。我在《心理历史》系列中想表达的是，微观即宏观。就像你可以对一个国家或帝国进行心理分析一样，你也可以对构成它的人民进行心理分析。它们的运作方式是一样的，它们以同样的方式进行防御。每一个官僚机构的行为都和个人头脑中的官僚机构一模一样。后来我看了克里斯托弗·诺兰的《奥德赛》，里面有一些主题让我深思。我在想：“天哪，我接下来该做哪一个？”然后它们在我的脑海里融合在了一起，我想：“好吧，我不知道。如果我能快速完成，也许因为它们本质上是同一回事，或者触及了
on the same thing, this will be a coherent essay. It's not coherent. I won't release it. So if you're listening to it, I think it was at least good enough to hit post. But I'll start with the FDA study. So the FDA study, in June of 2024, the FDA started doing this process that they made this decision that's now getting a little bit of publicity because PTA. S-D steps back in the news for a couple of reasons.
相同的东西，这会是一篇连贯的文章。”如果它不连贯，我就不会发布。所以如果你正在听，我想它至少足够好到可以发布了。但我先从FDA的研究说起。在2024年6月，FDA开始进行这个过程，他们做出了一个决定，现在正受到一些关注，因为PTSD（创伤后应激障碍）又因为几个原因上了新闻。
And then also, I think some people that didn't like the result of how it was done, started talking about it and got in the news. But basically, they were MDMA or ecstasy by its street name. I've never taken it. I've never even had a patient that's actually taken it. I've had patients that have taken mushrooms and psilocybin in kind of psilocybin, or psilocybin, or ketamine in kind of a healing environment. Some of them got better and liked it.
此外，我认为一些不喜欢研究结果的人开始讨论它，并引起了新闻报道。但基本上，他们研究的是MDMA，也就是街头俗称的“摇头丸”。我从没用过它，甚至从未有过服用过它的病人。我有过服用蘑菇、裸盖菇素或氯胺酮的病人，是在某种治疗环境下进行的。有些人好转了，也喜欢这种体验。
It made a lot of them worse. because dissociatives and psychedelics, ketamine tends to make people that are dissociative, dissociate more. And psilocybin sometimes will unlock things that people can't contain. You know, you go back into the trauma, but you don't have a good experience. You don't have a better experience that resolves it.
但它让很多人变得更糟。因为解离剂和迷幻剂，氯胺酮往往会让那些容易解离的人解离得更严重。而裸盖菇素有时会释放出人们无法控制的东西。你知道，你回到了创伤中，但你并没有获得良好的体验，也没有获得能解决问题的更好体验。
You actually have a worse one. So it turns out in the studies, you know, ketamine was kind of positioned as this thing that was this miracle drug. Then we found out, it's just another tool. It works for these things, but not for those things. psilocybin is something that is a non-specific amplifier you know if you're not in control of the experience or you're expecting the drug to do it for you um which sometimes uh trauma with a personality cluster B type you know a subset does they want to put pill that makes me better but they don't view
你反而经历了一次更糟糕的体验。事实证明，在研究中，氯胺酮曾被定位为一种灵丹妙药。后来我们发现，它只是另一种工具。它对某些问题有效，但对另一些问题无效。裸盖菇素是一种非特异性的放大器，如果你无法控制这种体验，或者你指望药物为你解决问题——有时患有B类人格障碍的创伤患者确实会这样，他们想要一颗能让自己好起来的药丸，但他们并不把这
it as a process it sometimes can make you a lot worse and it can give you a worse trauma um the results from the 2024 FDA study mdMA turns out not doing that i don't have any experience with it I'm just I'm just walking you through the study. The results are actually the best that anyone has ever produced for any drug that treats PTSD. Then not put a band-aid on the symptoms, like giving somebody a sedative or something, or a stimulant or, you know, or an antidepressant to try and take the edge off and then a pill for sleep and then a pill for that. Not band-aid stuff. Treating it. Not treating the symptoms.
视为一个过程——它有时会让你变得更糟，甚至造成更严重的创伤。2024年FDA关于MDMA的研究结果显示，它并非如此。我没有任何相关经验，我只是在带你梳理这项研究。结果实际上是目前为止治疗PTSD的所有药物中最好的。不是像给某人服用镇静剂、兴奋剂或抗抑郁药那样给症状贴上创可贴，试图缓解症状，然后再吃一颗安眠药，再吃一颗别的药。这不是贴创可贴，这是在治疗，不是治疗症状。
Treating the thing. Two-thirds of the people who went through treatment no longer met criteria. It cured them. And then 85 to 90% of people had a huge improvement, even if they still had, you know, met criteria for PTSD. No drug has ever come close. No drug has ever done anything like that. And the committee said, yeah, it's self-evident. Look, this is the results.
而是在治疗病根。三分之二接受治疗的人不再符合诊断标准，它治愈了他们。85%到90%的人有了巨大的改善，即使他们仍然符合PTSD的诊断标准。没有任何药物能与之相比，没有任何药物能做到这一点。委员会说：“是的，这是显而易见的。看，这就是结果。”
Here they are. But we don't know if it's evidence-based or not. We don't know if it works. We can't know. Science hasn't said that it's evidence-based or not. And the reason that we can't know is because in a randomized controlled trial, which is the gold standard of doing research for things that are objective, I'll give it to them, like, you know, cancer drugs.
“结果就在这里。但我们不知道它是否是循证的。我们不知道它是否有效。我们无法知道。科学还没有说它是循证的。”我们无法知道的原因是，在随机对照试验中——这是研究客观事物的黄金标准，我承认这一点，比如癌症药物。
Like if you want to see if does vitamin C make glaucoma, you know, get better or worse. Well, you can just measure the glaucoma pretty objectively after, you know, somebody does vitamin C. Psychology, again, like I said over and over, it's a process of multiple processes that you have to be aware of. You know, the glaucoma cell doesn't know whether you took vitamin C or not. the little eye cell. Brains tend to know when they are changing. So the reason that the FDA had to just throw out the results and say we still can't know if this is evidence-based or not
比如你想看看维生素C是否能让青光眼好转或恶化。好吧，在某人服用维生素C后，你可以相当客观地测量青光眼。但心理学，正如我反复说过的，是一个你必须意识到的多重过程。你知道，青光眼细胞并不知道你是否服用了维生素C，那是小小的眼细胞。但大脑往往知道自己何时在发生变化。所以FDA不得不抛弃这些结果，说我们仍然无法知道这是否是循证的，
is because to do a randomized controlled trial, you have to have a placebo. And a placebo in Sykes things, a lot of times it's cited as 35, but technically, depending on what you're studying, the placebo effects, which is somebody may just get better because they think that they had an intervention, even if the intervention didn't work.
是因为要进行随机对照试验，你必须有安慰剂。在心理学研究中，安慰剂效应通常被引用为35%，但严格来说，取决于你研究的内容，安慰剂效应是指某人可能仅仅因为认为自己接受了干预而好转，即使干预本身并没有起作用。
They may trick themselves into getting better. It's normally 30 to 40% depending on what you're studying. So if you're going to say, does this antidepressant work, you have to give half the people a sugar pill and half the people a real pill. Because 35%, 30 to 40% of that improvement in the group that you gave the real pill to, it may just be fake. You've got to compare it to the other group to make sure the placebo is controlled for. And it is very silly in this study because when you give somebody MDMA, if you know anything about ecstasy, it's a rave drug, it's a club drug. It's a drug that gives you a drug trip. And to cure PTSD turns out you have to give people a pretty high dose of drug enough to make them go on a trip.
他们可能会欺骗自己好转。通常在30%到40%之间，取决于你研究的内容。所以如果你要说“这种抗抑郁药有效吗”，你必须给一半人吃糖丸，另一半人吃真药。因为在服用真药的那组人中，35%到40%的改善可能只是假的。你必须将其与另一组进行比较，以确保安慰剂效应被控制住。在这项研究中这非常荒谬，因为当你给某人服用MDMA时，如果你了解摇头丸，它是一种狂欢药物，一种俱乐部药物。它是一种能让你产生幻觉的药物。事实证明，要治愈PTSD，你必须给人们服用相当高剂量的药物，足以让他们产生幻觉。
So when you give people a sugar pill, they can figure out whether or not they had a trip. And because they can figure it out, they can't be. be placebo can't be controlled for because the placebo has to be blinded and if they say I know it's placebo or if they say oh wow that was a great drug trip my PTSD went away then your randomized controlled trial was not done right so you can't know that it worked or not we're doing science guys and that is my critique of this system because if you as you know a thinking rational person say, okay, we want to study whether or not this makes somebody better. But in order to study whether or not it makes them better, what we have to do is we're going to have somebody
所以当你给人们服用糖丸时，他们能分辨出自己是否产生了幻觉。因为他们能分辨出来，所以安慰剂效应无法被控制，因为安慰剂必须是盲测的。如果他们说“我知道这是安慰剂”，或者如果他们说“哇，那是一次很棒的幻觉之旅，我的PTSD消失了”，那么你的随机对照试验就没有做好。所以你无法知道它是否有效。我们正在做科学，伙计们，这就是我对这个系统的批评。因为如果你作为一个有思想、理性的人说：“好吧，我们想研究这是否能让某人好转。但为了研究它是否能让他们好转，我们必须让某人
care about them. We're going to have somebody talk to them. We're going to have them think about their issue. We're going to have them reflect on it while they do this screener and we see, you know, how it's affected their life. And they're going to go through this process of us diagnosing them to see if they check these boxes. And then we're going to have them tell them what the treatment is going to involve. And then they're going to think about it. And they're going to going to be working with somebody who's bigger than the issue who's not overwhelmed or scared, you know, these mental health things, they're going to be talking about it in order to do all this. Well, if some of them get better, that's the placebo effect, because that's not real depression
关心他们。我们要让某人与他们交谈。我们要让他们思考自己的问题。我们要让他们在做筛查时反思这个问题，看看它如何影响了他们的生活。他们将经历我们诊断他们的过程，看看他们是否符合这些标准。然后我们要让他们知道治疗将涉及什么。然后他们会思考这个问题。他们将与一个比问题本身更强大、不会感到不知所措或害怕的人一起工作。你知道，这些心理健康问题，他们会为了做这一切而谈论它。好吧，如果他们中的一些人好转了，那就是安慰剂效应，因为那不是真正的抑郁，
if doing all that made the depression go away. Because none of that stuff can matter. None of that stuff can be part of the mechanism of action, the intervention that's getting them better. None of that stuff can be part of psychology. What if that is the mechanism of action? What if that reason that 30 to 40% of people in these studies get better is because that is something that you should be adding back into the profession and understanding is an intervention, is loving and caring and being present and reflecting on these things?
如果做所有这些事情就能让抑郁消失的话。因为所有这些事情都不重要。所有这些事情都不能成为作用机制的一部分，不能成为让他们好转的干预措施。所有这些事情都不能成为心理学的一部分。如果那正是作用机制呢？如果这些研究中30%到40%的人好转的原因，正是因为那是你应该重新加入到专业中并理解为一种干预的东西呢？即爱、关心、在场并反思这些事情？
You can measure a cancer drug, whether or not it works. Does it make the tumor get smaller? Yes or no? with a randomized controlled trial. You can't do it with psychology because these are processes that we will always be aware of. And when you touch the thing, you've made it different. Even if you give it a placebo, you've made it different. And if the science can't see that, it's a science of something other than psychology.
你可以通过随机对照试验来衡量一种癌症药物是否有效。肿瘤变小了吗？是还是否？你不能在心理学中这样做，因为这些是我们永远会意识到的过程。当你触碰它时，你就已经改变了它。即使你给它一个安慰剂，你也已经改变了它。如果科学看不见这一点，那它研究的就不是心理学。
Because psych science will always, always have that as part of the process. And that is what the academic model has resisted for 25 years. more CBT, more biomedical model. That's the gold standard because those things can pass a randomized controlled trial while this other stuff is either too hard to research or too messy. And oh, well, shit, you know, every time we've done this, though, for the past 25, 30 years, and we've set it's the gold standard and we put it more into practice and we put it more into schools. Mental health outcomes get worse. Results of people going to therapy get worse. It's failing to be validated by reality.
因为心理科学永远、永远会将此作为过程的一部分。而这正是学术模式25年来一直抵制的。更多的CBT（认知行为疗法），更多的生物医学模式。那是黄金标准，因为这些东西可以通过随机对照试验，而其他东西要么太难研究，要么太混乱。该死，你知道，在过去的25到30年里，每次我们这样做，我们都说这是黄金标准，我们把它更多地投入实践，更多地投入学校。心理健康结果却变得更糟。人们接受治疗的结果变得更糟。它未能被现实所验证。
Why? Well, it can't be that the system that we're doing this stuff based on is wrong. For 45 years, research has been telling us the same thing, and it's not a flaw in the research. It is the finding. The mind can tell when it's being measured, and it changes in response to being measured. That is a property of the thing itself. Tennessee Williams point about, I set a jar in Tennessee, and then all of a sudden, the hill I set the jar unchanged, and the jar reflected the hill.
为什么？好吧，不可能说我们基于这些东西的系统是错的。45年来，研究一直告诉我们同样的事情，这不是研究的缺陷，这就是发现。大脑在被测量时能感觉到，并会因被测量而发生改变。这是事物本身的属性。田纳西·威廉姆斯关于“我在田纳西放了一个罐子”的观点，突然间，我放罐子的山丘没有改变，但罐子反映了山丘。
you know, it is exactly what a science of the mind would have to have an understanding of to actually be a science of the mind. If you go through a process where you know that you are changing, then knowing is part of the change. And there is no version of you that change without knowing. And a science of change that cannot allow the person to know that they are changing or that they are being affected or that they are being connected is a science of something else. It is not a science of psychology. So don't send me an email and ask me if I like science. I just know how it works. And I'm aware of when that science is very big.
你知道，这正是心理科学为了真正成为心理科学所必须理解的东西。如果你经历了一个你知道自己正在改变的过程，那么“知道”就是改变的一部分。没有一种版本的你是可以在不知道的情况下改变的。而一种不能允许人知道自己正在改变、正在受到影响或正在建立联系的改变科学，是其他东西的科学。它不是心理学的科学。所以不要给我发邮件问我是否喜欢科学。我只是知道它是如何运作的，并且我知道这种科学在什么时候是非常大的。
And the committees fall back, you know, to defend them a little bit, there were problems with the study. There were some misconduct by researchers at some of the trial sites. But there always is that. That's why you do a pure review to point out the problem. Those were not big enough to throw out the result that they found. you know, the thing being treated and the thing being measured and the ruler are all the same object.
委员会退缩了，为了稍微为他们辩护一下，研究确实存在问题。在一些试验点，研究人员存在一些不当行为。但这种情况总是存在。这就是为什么你要进行同行评审来指出问题。这些问题不足以推翻他们发现的结果。你知道，被治疗的对象、被测量的对象和尺子都是同一个物体。
They're all you. And that is not something that happens when you're studying effects outside of the mind. Even when you're self-reporting it and turning it into a number by hitting one through 10 on the little number line, the thing being treated, the thing being measured, and the ruler are the same thing. That's not a phenomenon that happens in physics. you know, they are all you. And there is an instrument that separates the thinking
它们都是你。当你研究大脑之外的影响时，这种情况不会发生。即使当你进行自我报告并将其转化为数字，在数字线上点击1到10时，被治疗的对象、被测量的对象和尺子也是同一个东西。这不是物理学中会发生的现象。你知道，它们都是你。有一个工具将思考
from the thinking that you were thinking. It was never multiple things, though. It is all three, but it's also one. I'm sorry, I'll get back on track. I'm going into my, like, rabbit hole in my head too much. But we've turned science into a ritual. The randomized controlled trial is the ceremony, and you feed the question in,
与你正在思考的思考分离开来。但它从来不是多个东西。它既是这三者，也是一个整体。抱歉，我回到正轨。我太深入自己的思维死胡同了。但我们已经把科学变成了一种仪式。随机对照试验就是仪式，你把问题输入进去，
and you turn the little crank on the machine, and the truth comes out at the bottom. And even if you know the truth is true, if it doesn't come out of the machine, you can't know that it's true. That's what the FDA's saying. And so if something is true, but it didn't come out of the crank, it's not allowed to be true yet. The cure can be sitting in front of you and it can be self-evident. We could help all these people, two-thirds of the people, but we're not permitted to know that yet. And keep in mind, these people are largely, they would tell you, these researchers would largely tell you that they are not religious.
你转动机器上的小曲柄，真相就从底部出来了。即使你知道真相是真的，如果它不是从机器里出来的，你就不能知道它是真的。这就是FDA所说的。所以如果某事是真的，但它没有从曲柄里出来，它还不被允许是真的。治愈方法可能就摆在你面前，而且显而易见。我们可以帮助所有这些人，三分之二的人，但我们还不被允许知道这一点。请记住，这些人大部分——他们会告诉你，这些研究人员大部分会告诉你他们不是宗教人士。
But this thing is a sacrament that we are doing. We don't run trials, randomized control, trials on something like do parachutes work if you if you jump out of a plane do you survive more if you have a parachute you couldn't run that run to mouse controlled trial half the jumpers get a shoot and the other one gets a backpack but it's full of pots and pans like a looney tunes cartoon and the control group you know gets this empty one that's got the pots and pans in it and nobody is told which one we skip that one and not because we're unscientific the effect for do you survive a plane crash with a parachute even though maybe sometimes the parachute doesn't work. Most of the time, vast majority of the time,
但这东西是我们正在进行的圣礼。我们不会对诸如“降落伞是否有效”之类的事情进行随机对照试验。如果你跳出飞机，如果你有降落伞，你存活的几率更高吗？你无法进行那种随机对照试验。一半跳伞者得到一个降落伞，另一半得到一个背包，但里面装满了锅碗瓢盆，就像《乐一通》动画片一样。对照组得到的是装满锅碗瓢盆的空背包，没人被告知哪一个是真的。我们跳过了那个，不是因为我们不科学。关于“你带着降落伞在飞机失事中幸存”的效果，即使有时降落伞打不开，大多数时候，绝大多数时候，
100% of people would like to have one. That effect is so obvious that demanding research on it, demanding a trial, not being able to know what we know there, that would be unscientific. To ask to run a trial on that would be so stupid. It would be unscientific. But if we did run it, nobody would throw out the data set because the subjects figured out which group they were in on the way down.
100%的人都想要一个。这种效果太明显了，以至于要求进行研究，要求进行试验，无法知道我们所知道的，那才是反科学的。要求进行那种试验太愚蠢了。那是反科学的。但如果我们真的进行了试验，没人会因为受试者在下落过程中发现了自己在哪一组而丢弃数据集。
But that's what the FDA did with MDMA. And again, I don't have experience with the MDMA. I've never even had a patient that's done it that has told me about it. I've never done it. I'm not, I'm only going through this data and the thought process. So, you know, there were, there were other objections. But those are the same objections that I see, a small misconduct in the studies. Like in every trial for an antidepressant.
但这就是FDA对MDMA所做的。再说一次，我没有MDMA的经验。我甚至从未有过服用过它并告诉我的病人。我从没用过。我不是，我只是在梳理这些数据和思考过程。所以，你知道，还有其他的反对意见。但那些和我看到的反对意见是一样的，即研究中的小规模不当行为。就像在每一种抗抑郁药的试验中一样。
or antipsychotic, even though there's not as many of those that we do anymore, it flies through these things. You know, the proposal was real, you know, give the controlled group this low dose of something. This is the fix that they proposed, as they said, you know, we'll just give the control group a lower dose of something so that they're a little confused. They can tell that there's something psychoactive in their system, like maybe an antidepressant. but that still isn't going to work. It's never going to be good enough because MDMA,
或者抗精神病药，尽管我们现在做的这类试验没那么多了，它在这些事情中飞速通过。你知道，提议是真实的，你知道，给对照组服用低剂量的某种东西。这是他们提出的修正方案，他们说：“我们只是给对照组服用低剂量的某种东西，让他们有点困惑。”他们能感觉到系统中有某种精神活性物质，比如抗抑郁药。但这仍然行不通。它永远不会足够好，因为MDMA，
at the doses you have to give it to care of PTSD, has such a strong effect that if 40% of the group is going through ego death and thinking that they're connected to the universe and that time is not real, they're going to figure out that they were on this drug. So even the proposed fix will not go anywhere. There's no knock-off effect of facing your own mortality. And that's what the people are reporting.
在治疗PTSD所需的剂量下，具有如此强烈的效果，以至于如果40%的人正在经历自我消亡，认为他们与宇宙相连，时间不是真实的，他们会发现自己服用了这种药物。所以即使是提议的修正方案也无济于事。面对自己的死亡没有替代效应。而这正是人们所报告的。
When you read the data in these trials, like as much of the raw data as they put out there, you know, people come out of this treatment and they're talking about a reconciliation with death. They're talking about a dissolving of the self. They're talking about a reordering of what their life was for, you know, meaning, a change in meaning in that way. And all things that are probably more important than the checklist of symptoms we call PTSD.
当你阅读这些试验中的数据时，比如他们发布的大部分原始数据，你知道，人们从这种治疗中走出来，谈论的是与死亡的和解。他们谈论的是自我的消解。他们谈论的是对他们生活意义的重新排序，你知道，意义，那种意义上的改变。所有这些事情可能都比我们称之为PTSD的症状清单更重要。
And then we hand them a form asking them to rate from zero to four, they're trouble concentrating after they've had those experiences and they want to talk about that and then we have to use that to figure out if the drug did something that was helping them you can't weigh a resurrection on a scale that counts symptoms you can't weigh this huge resurrection of like I really thought I was better off dead and now I'm not are you concentrating better though zero to four we have to be scientific like a science earns the name through agreement on three things. This is what makes it a science. What is the object? What is the method and what is it for? What's the purpose? If you said, okay, there's seven schools of marine biologists in academic marine
然后我们递给他们一张表格，让他们在经历这些体验后，对他们的注意力集中困难程度进行0到4的评分，他们想谈论这些，然后我们必须用它来判断药物是否对他们有帮助。你不能用计算症状的秤来衡量重生。你不能衡量这种巨大的重生，比如“我真的以为死了更好，但现在我不这么想了”。但你注意力更集中了吗？0到4。我们必须科学。科学通过在三件事上达成一致来赢得它的名字。这就是使它成为科学的原因。对象是什么？方法是什么？它是为了什么？目的是什么？如果你说，好吧，学术海洋生物学中有七个流派，
biology and they can't really agree on what marine biology is doing. I mean, marine biology is marine biology because 100% of marine biologists know that they're studying life in the ocean. If only 13% of them thought that, if there were seven competing schools in academic marine biology like there are an academic psych that we're doing and saying things like this, you might be within your rights to conclude that marine biology was fake. We run tests on astrology being fake all the time without blinking. We run it on homeopathy, homeopathic medicine being fake all the time without blinking. But we don't run studies on like, is economics fake? I mean, you guys are supposed to understand how money works and markets and all these things. And it seems like if a single one of you
他们无法真正就海洋生物学在做什么达成一致。我的意思是，海洋生物学之所以是海洋生物学，是因为100%的海洋生物学家都知道他们在研究海洋中的生命。如果只有13%的人这么认为，如果学术海洋生物学中有七个相互竞争的流派，就像学术心理学中那样，我们正在做并说出这样的话，你可能有权得出结论说海洋生物学是假的。我们一直在测试占星术是否是假的，眼睛都不眨一下。我们一直在测试顺势疗法是否是假的，眼睛都不眨一下。但我们不会对“经济学是假的吗”进行研究。我的意思是，你们应该了解金钱是如何运作的，市场以及所有这些事情。如果你们中有一个人
figured out how to write a book and say, hey, recession's going to come in 2005, a recession's going to come in 2008, a recession is going to come in 2014. And this is what it's going to look like. Because this was a hard science, you'd be like the most valuable guy in the world. You'd be able see into the future with your math, which is what it's for us to see this stuff coming. None of them can. But I mean, economics is a respected science, right? I talk about Porter all the time, theater reporter. Trust in numbers is still a great book. Everybody should read it. Again, just a review, if you didn't listen to the, you know, psycho history series, his argument or any of the other things I've done, like his argument is always that soft sciences are pretty insecure. And so because they are
想出如何写一本书并说：“嘿，2005年会有衰退，2008年会有衰退，2014年会有衰退。这就是它看起来的样子。”因为这是一门硬科学，你会成为世界上最有价值的人。你将能够用你的数学预见未来，这就是我们预见这些事情的目的。他们中没有人能做到。但我的意思是，经济学是一门受人尊敬的科学，对吧？我一直在谈论波特，西奥多·波特。《对数字的信任》仍然是一本好书。每个人都应该读一读。再说一次，只是回顾一下，如果你没有听《心理历史》系列，他的论点或我做的任何其他事情，比如他的论点总是软科学相当不安全。所以因为它们
insecure and they're afraid of just sort of knowing what they can know and not knowing what they can't, they have to pretend that they can know everything by reaching for numbers. And then they use the insecure fields. They reach for numbers because the numbers looks like it fell out of the sky, like it came from heaven. And then if you have a number, nobody can argue with you. And he calls that metaphors from distance.
不安全，而且害怕仅仅知道他们能知道的东西，而不知道他们不能知道的东西，他们必须假装通过伸手去拿数字来了解一切。然后他们使用不安全的领域。他们伸手去拿数字，因为数字看起来像是从天上掉下来的，就像来自天堂一样。然后如果你有一个数字，没人能和你争论。他称之为“距离隐喻”。
But we forget that numbers really are just metaphors, because the number is not the thing. The number is just a measurement of one aspect of a thing and the way that we can measure it. In the same way that a metaphor is a very broad description of a phenomenon. So we're numbers. they're not the truth. It's there to protect you from having to defend that your judgment is not the truth. And I mean, again, in the psychohistory series, my field already admitted all this about itself and then ignored the admission. Like in 2013, the National Institute of Mental Health said the DSM-5 is fake. The DSM has been fake for a long time.
但我们忘记了数字实际上只是隐喻，因为数字不是事物本身。数字只是事物的一个方面的测量，以及我们测量它的方式。就像隐喻是对现象的一种非常广泛的描述。所以我们是数字。它们不是真相。它在那里是为了保护你，让你不必为你的判断不是真相而辩护。我的意思是，再说一次，在《心理历史》系列中，我的领域已经承认了所有这些，然后忽略了这种承认。比如在2013年，美国国家心理健康研究所说DSM-5是假的。DSM很长一段时间以来都是假的。
None of these categories are valid. They're not replicable. They're not real. And you've had 30 years to correct that and you've gone in the wrong direction, so we're throwing it out. But therapists still have a copy that is in 5TR, the newest version of that book that came out, you know, two years ago on their desk. Why? Why is there a new version of that book? What is it for? Who is this for anymore? We have to have the numbers. We talked about the Stardee study, which is, you know, the biggest study in the world that was the most rigorous, past the most peer review.
这些类别都不是有效的。它们不可复制。它们不是真实的。你已经有30年的时间来纠正这一点，但你走错了方向，所以我们把它扔掉了。但治疗师的桌子上仍然有一本DSM-5-TR，那是两年前出版的最新版本。为什么？为什么那本书有新版本？它是为了什么？这到底是给谁看的？我们必须有数字。我们谈到了Stardee研究，你知道，那是世界上最大、最严谨、通过了最多同行评审的研究。
And in the end of it, it found turned out the researchers couldn't tell the difference between 3% and 98. They accidentally thought 98% of people got better. Turns out it was 3. Because they were all looking at their little numbers and it was so complicated. and no one was looking at the whole thing. I mean, economics is the same thing, right? Like, I wanted to talk about this because I wanted to say that all of the things that I said about psychology are equally true for a whole lot of other things that run our world. Did you know that there's not actually a Nobel Prize in economics?
最后，研究人员发现他们无法区分3%和98%。他们意外地认为98%的人好转了。结果发现只有3%。因为他们都在看他们的小数字，而且太复杂了。没人看整体。我的意思是，经济学也是一样，对吧？我想谈谈这个，因为我想说，我关于心理学所说的一切，对于运行我们世界的许多其他事情同样适用。你知道经济学其实没有诺贝尔奖吗？
You know, the thing that gets announced every October actually was like made up in the 60s, this group of bankers. It was a Swiss bank that was really, or Swedish bank, that was really, um, famous and they wanted economic policy to be treated as science, not politics. Because people were treating money like politics. Why do you say that the interest rate should be that? Why should you decide that these people all of a sudden have a million dollars more? That seems like the wrong answer. I'd like to have a say in that. They didn't really want people to have a say in that. They wanted it to be a science. It was just numbers told us that the money had to do this. And so they said, if we give all this money to the Nobel Prize Association, then can we have, um,
你知道，每年10月宣布的那个奖项实际上是60年代编造的，是一群银行家。那是一家瑞士银行，或者瑞典银行，非常有名，他们希望经济政策被视为科学，而不是政治。因为人们把金钱当作政治来对待。你为什么说利率应该是那样？你为什么决定这些人突然多了一百万美元？这似乎是错误的答案。我想对此有发言权。他们并不真的想让人们有发言权。他们希望它成为一门科学。只是数字告诉我们钱必须这样做。所以他们说，如果我们把所有的钱都给诺贝尔奖协会，那么我们可以有，嗯，
If we do that, can we have somebody, somebody's calling me and I turn on my phone? Then if we do that, can we just make up a Nobel Prize in Economics and give it to the people that we think should have it? And the people running the Nobel committee at that point wanted the money and took it. The Nobel family, the surviving people who are actually pretty angry at that because that's not what Alfred Nobel wanted. He wanted it to be about science. And you're changing the definition of what science is by pretending that if you can measure something in numbers, it becomes a science. Well, I mean, I can measure the dragon in my dreams in numbers.
如果我们这样做，我们可以编造一个诺贝尔经济学奖，并把它颁发给我们认为应该得到它的人吗？当时负责诺贝尔委员会的人想要这笔钱，就接受了。诺贝尔家族，幸存的那些人实际上对此非常生气，因为那不是阿尔弗雷德·诺贝尔想要的。他希望它是关于科学的。而你正在通过假装如果你能用数字衡量某事，它就变成了科学，来改变科学的定义。好吧，我的意思是，我可以用数字衡量我梦中的龙。
I don't think that's science. So Friedrich Hayek, who's a darling of like the rugged capitalists, he's a capitalist, you know, free market guy. In 1974, he gets it. And he, in his acceptance speech, he says, no economist should ever have this kind of authority. Like, this award that you just gave me is a joke. This is stupid. Like, this isn't what we're doing.
我不认为那是科学。所以弗里德里希·哈耶克，他是粗犷资本主义者的宠儿，他是一个资本主义者，你知道，自由市场的人。1974年，他明白了。在获奖感言中，他说，没有任何经济学家应该拥有这种权威。这个你刚刚颁给我的奖项是个笑话。这很愚蠢。这不是我们在做的事情。
We're not really doing science. And then he called his lecture, I think, the pretense of knowledge. And he said that the medal was a costume. And then Gunnar Mirdal, who's a socialist, Hyac's opposite in every A. He was the co-winner. He also won. And so the socialist and the free market guy don't really agree on much.
我们并没有真正做科学。然后他把他的演讲命名为，我想是《知识的僭妄》。他说奖章是一件戏服。然后冈纳·缪达尔，一个社会主义者，哈耶克的对立面，他是共同获奖者。他也获奖了。所以社会主义者和自由市场的人在很多事情上并不一致。
If you read their papers, they are not going to have anything economic to say where they agree. But they both said, this medal is a fraud. When Miradol took it, he said, you should abolish this award. And Noble's family didn't like it either. But, you know, one descendant who was a member of the family, called the prize this PR coup, by economists to make themselves look legitimate. And another one said, this is a cuckoo's egg in the Nobel nest. Paul Romero, and he also won the Nobel Prize in Economics, he coined a word for the equations the economists to use. And he said, economists don't use math.
如果你读他们的论文，他们在经济上不会有任何共识。但他们都说，这枚奖章是欺诈。当缪达尔接受它时，他说：“你应该废除这个奖项。”诺贝尔家族也不喜欢它。但是，你知道，一位作为家族成员的后代称该奖项为经济学家为了让自己看起来合法而进行的公关政变。另一位说，这是诺贝尔巢穴里的杜鹃蛋。保罗·罗默，他也获得了诺贝尔经济学奖，他为经济学家使用的方程创造了一个词。他说，经济学家不使用数学。
They use mathiness to put ideas on this performative, rigorous process, while there's really a political reality that is hiding underneath that nobody can see. And the philosopher Tony Lawson explained, you know, that you can't work with these things in those ways. He said deductive math runs inside closed systems and sealed box. where the parts don't change. And the same causes will always produce the same effect. That's why algebra is algebra, because x minus two equals three, X, well, hold on, let me think about that in my head. X minus two equals three.
他们使用“数学味”来把想法放在这个表演性的、严谨的过程中，而实际上隐藏着一个没人能看到的政治现实。哲学家托尼·劳森解释说，你不能以那种方式处理这些事情。他说演绎数学在封闭系统和密封盒子里运行。其中部分不会改变。相同的原因总是产生相同的效果。这就是为什么代数是代数，因为X减2等于3，X，等等，让我脑子里想一下。X减2等于
This is how bad I am at math. X minus two equals, I'm leaving this in. X minus two equals three is always going to be five. But anyway, sorry, what Lawson was saying is that people are in open, system. We are historical and we react to being studied. So we do the opposite of last time just so that we feel free. And that's part of the math equation that makes us human that cannot be measured like x minus 2 equals 3 can be solved consistently in 1910 and then again in 2026 and you get the same answer. We have to realize that psychology is doing the same thing. We are historical and we react to being studied.
这就是我数学有多差。X减2等于3总是5。但无论如何，抱歉，劳森所说的是，人们处于开放系统中。我们是历史性的，我们对被研究做出反应。所以我们做与上次相反的事情，只是为了让我们感到自由。这是使我们成为人类的数学方程的一部分，它不能像X减2等于3那样在1910年和2026年被一致地解决并得到相同的答案。我们必须意识到心理学正在做同样的事情。我们是历史性的，我们对被研究做出反应。
We do the opposite of what we've done. before. So economics just shaves the people down until they fit the method and it assumes identical, rational robots with perfect information. And then it acts surprised every time the real economy refuses to behave like the equation. Because psychology makes the same move for the same reason. That's why it started to do something as stupid as the experiment that I just explained. You know, the models don't just describe the world badly, though. It's not like something's happening and we don't know what it is. That's not my point.
我们做与以前相反的事情。所以经济学只是把人削减到适合这个方法，它假设了拥有完美信息的、相同的理性机器人。然后它每次在真实经济拒绝像方程那样表现时都表现得很惊讶。因为心理学出于同样的原因采取了同样的举措。这就是为什么它开始做像我刚才解释的那样愚蠢的实验。你知道，模型不仅仅是糟糕地描述了世界。并不是说发生了什么我们不知道的事情。那不是我的观点。
My point is that people are reacting based on the model. The models don't just do a bad job of reflecting reality. They reshape reality. Like there's a sociologist, Donald McKenzie, and he calls a financial model an engine, not a camera, because it doesn't photograph the market. It actually drives it. when everyone adopted this the options pricing formula in the 80s, then traders priced the way the formula said they should price it. And all of a sudden, the history of options trading was different
我的观点是，人们正在根据模型做出反应。模型不仅仅是在反映现实方面做得不好。它们重塑了现实。比如有一位社会学家，唐纳德·麦肯齐，他称金融模型为引擎，而不是相机，因为它不拍摄市场。它实际上驱动了市场。当每个人在80年代采用这个期权定价公式时，交易员们就按照公式说他们应该定价的方式定价。突然间，期权交易的历史就不同了
forever because people were saying, well, I'm not following the model. I'm not doing it right. If the model didn't exist, they would have been trading differently and you would have been studying something else. So future models of studying options trading were just studying what those guys were doing in that model when a fund full of geniuses, you know, running that formula put a crater in the financial system, nobody was like, oh, oops, we shouldn't have done that. They were just like, well, we couldn't see it coming. But it was because people were using a model that they thought was supposed to study the thing and it changed what they were doing as the thing, as traders, as people being part of the economy. I don't want to say economists because they weren't studying it. They were doing it.
永远地，因为人们说：“好吧，我没有遵循模型。我没做对。”如果模型不存在，他们会以不同的方式交易，你也会研究别的东西。所以研究期权交易的未来模型只是在研究那些人在那个模型中在做什么。当一群天才，你知道，运行那个公式的基金在金融系统中造成了一个坑时，没人说：“哦，哎呀，我们不该那样做。”他们只是说：“好吧，我们没预见到。”但这是因为人们在使用一个他们认为应该研究该事物的模型，而它改变了他们作为交易员、作为作为经济一部分的人所做的事情。我不想说经济学家，因为他们没有研究它。他们在做它。
as markets. The map didn't just conquer the territory. It killed all the people, you know, in the territory. Psychiatry, you know, caught that same insecurity. And the, you know, that it was this runt sitting next to medicine, but used to be called alienist. And then it was called neurologist and then it was called, you know, but all the, all these things. And, but we're real doctors. And so the word for what it did is reification, you know, treating something fluid and alive as all of a sudden something static.
作为市场。地图不仅征服了领土。它杀死了领土上的所有人。精神病学，你知道，也染上了同样的不安全感。它曾经是医学旁边的小个子，但过去被称为“异化论者”。然后它被称为神经学家，然后它被称为，你知道，所有这些东西。但我们是真正的医生。它所做的事情的词是“具体化”，你知道，把流动的、活生生的东西突然当作静态的东西来对待。
This manual draws this hard line where there is only one gradient. Well, it turns out there's a rainbow. Well, you know there's two categories. Could you put all the colors in the rainbow into one of these two boxes, please? Oh, warm colors and blue colors. That's a great idea. A rainbow has two parts now.
这本手册划出了一条硬线，只有一个梯度。好吧，事实证明有一个彩虹。好吧，你知道有两个类别。你能把彩虹里的所有颜色放进这两个盒子里吗？哦，暖色和冷色。那是个好主意。彩虹现在有两个部分了。
The rating scales that we use in research or even worse. You know, we ask you to feel from zero to three and you're doing arithmetic to a feeling like it's good and bad and not just an experience that you are having that could be described. Feelings aren't always moral or amoral, good or bad, pleasant or unpleasant. Sometimes they are an experience that is just alive and changing, but that's hard to study. You know, the form says 15, so you're carrying 15 units of depression. And everything that makes the suffering yours, the grief, the marriage, the lost job, gets swept off the table as noise because it doesn't fit in the box. No, you feel 15 depression.
我们在研究中使用的评分量表甚至更糟。你知道，我们让你从0到3感受，你是在对一种感觉做算术，就像它是好是坏，而不是你正在经历的、可以被描述的体验。感觉并不总是道德或非道德的，好的或坏的，愉快的或不愉快的。有时它们是一种活生生的、不断变化的体验，但这很难研究。你知道，表格上写着15，所以你带着15个单位的抑郁。而所有使痛苦成为你自己的东西，悲伤、婚姻、失去的工作，都被当作噪音扫地出门，因为它不适合那个盒子。不，你感觉到了15个单位的抑郁。
And so you've disconnected them from the environment that psychology is afraid of. And it is the connection to the environment that makes psychology an inherently political science. Because if you follow the evidence, if you follow the science, what it's saying is that there's a lot of things in our world that we probably should change because the way they're done is deeply unhealthy. And it's fucking up the way we think. So when you say that, when you write that book, people will say, oh, you're an academic, you're a psychologist, you shouldn't be so political. But what they won't say is that when they write the book,
所以你把他们从心理学所恐惧的环境中剥离了出来。而正是这种与环境的联系，使心理学成为一门本质上的政治科学。因为如果你遵循证据，遵循科学，它所表达的就是：我们世界中有很多事情可能应该改变，因为它们处理问题的方式极其不健康。而且这正在搞砸我们的思维方式。所以当你这么说，当你写那本书时，人们会说，哦，你是个学者，你是个心理学家，你不应该这么政治化。但他们不会说的是，当他们写书时，
the biomedical model works and psychology should be cut off for the environment and these things just exist. They don't want to see that as politics. And it is, you know, in the same way that people, and I'm not picking aside, you know, but when people said like, oh, this guy is kneeling down for the national anthem to protest something in the Super Bowl, football shouldn't be political.
生物医学模型是有效的，心理学应该与环境隔绝，而这些事物只是客观存在。他们不想把这看作政治。但它确实是，你知道，就像人们——我不是在选边站，你知道——但当人们说，哦，这家伙在超级碗比赛中为抗议某事而单膝下跪，橄榄球不应该政治化。
And I was like, dude, I'm not a football fan. I've been to three games in my life, but they were like fighter jets that flew over the stadium in American flag fireworks. And Toby Keith sung a song about God bless the troops or something. You just don't like the kind of politics that they're doing. It wasn't apolitical before. You just agreed with it.
我当时就想，老兄，我不是橄榄球迷。我这辈子只看过三场比赛，但现场有喷气式战斗机飞过体育场，有美国国旗烟花。托比·基思还唱了一首关于“上帝保佑军队”之类的歌。你只是不喜欢他们所搞的那种政治。它以前并非非政治化。你只是赞同它而已。
Whether or not you see it doesn't mean that it isn't. And psychology in that way will always be political. And so when you write the book saying it shouldn't be political, you're saying that you don't agree with the politics that the science is indicating. We decided that therapy has to work the way that a drug works. And one active ingredient, you know, everything else is noise that you subtract. There's only one ingredient that's active.
无论你是否看到它，并不意味着它不存在。心理学在这一点上将永远是政治性的。所以当你写书说它不应该政治化时，你是在说你不赞同科学所指出的那种政治。我们决定了治疗必须像药物一样起作用。一种活性成分，你知道，其他一切都是你需要减去的噪音。只有一种成分是有效的。
Therapy never worked that way because psychology doesn't work that way. It worked by the opposite move, putting you in contact with a crowd of realities at once, your past, your body, the person across from you, and the things that you've referred. used to look at for years. Half of that contact makes you feel worse before it makes you feel better. And the upset is the medicine working. So we built a science that can only study single ingredients, and then we stood around confused about why it keeps failing to find the thing that heals. And in my field, the ritual has spent 50 years failing to find therapy's active ingredient because there's not one. Bruce Wampold, he spent his career talking about this.
治疗从来不是那样运作的，因为心理学不是那样运作的。它是通过相反的动作来运作的，让你同时接触到一群现实：你的过去、你的身体、你对面的人，以及你多年来一直关注的事物。这种接触的一半会让你在感觉好转之前感觉更糟。而这种不安正是药物在起作用。所以我们建立了一门只能研究单一成分的科学，然后我们站在一旁困惑为什么它总是无法找到治愈的东西。在我的领域，这种仪式已经花了50年时间试图找到治疗的活性成分，因为根本没有单一成分。布鲁斯·万波尔德，他毕生都在谈论这个问题。
You know, he compare real therapies head to head and the specific techniques don't matter. Remove the supposedly critical ingredient from a therapy and outcomes don't change. What heals is the relationship, one nervous system witnessed by another person. And the trial is a machine for removing context to isolate a variable. And in therapy, the context is the medicine. So the trial removes the medicine and then it measures what it's left. and then it says, oh, there was a weak effect. Well, maybe all the stuff that you threw out with the placebo effect
你知道，他对比了各种真实的疗法，具体的技巧并不重要。从疗法中移除所谓的关键成分，结果并不会改变。治愈的是关系，是一个神经系统被另一个人所见证。而临床试验是一种为了隔离变量而移除背景的机器。但在治疗中，背景就是药物。所以试验移除了药物，然后测量剩下的东西，然后说，哦，效果很弱。好吧，也许你作为安慰剂效应扔掉的所有东西，
that you said might be just making somebody think they were getting better when they weren't really getting better was actually healing them and you were refusing to study it. And the proof of what I'm saying has been sitting, if you want me to be more scientific, in these trials the whole time filed under the wrong name. The placebo response in psychiatric drug trials is enormous. like 40% is a huge chunk.
你所说的可能只是让人以为自己在好转而实际上并没有好转的东西，其实正在治愈他们，而你却拒绝研究它。如果你想让我更科学一点，我所说的证据一直都在那里，在这些试验中，只是被归档在了错误的名称下。精神科药物试验中的安慰剂反应是巨大的。比如40%，这是一个巨大的比例。
Most drugs don't do 40% effective that we approve. And by some analysis, it accounts for the most of what the drugs appear to do. The trial's whole job is to subtract that as contamination. Well, look at what that is made out of. The ritual of care is biologically active and alive. And our attempt to remove the ritual of care. and the connection to the human through AI portals and all this like horseshit that we've been peppering through the profession. Our attempt to remove that has made outcomes worse.
大多数我们批准的药物效果都没有达到40%。根据一些分析，它占了药物表现出的大部分作用。试验的全部工作就是把这部分当作污染减去。好吧，看看它是由什么组成的。关怀的仪式在生物学上是活跃且鲜活的。而我们试图通过人工智能门户网站和所有这些我们在职业中不断添加的废话来移除关怀仪式，以及与人的联系。我们试图移除它的尝试反而让结果变得更糟。
But we can't indict the science because the science has this political motivation to make sure that left or right. You think that that is the only way that we can ever study these things. And if you don't study them that way, you're not a serious person, even though it's made everything worse for 40 years. look what that made you. Meeting with a doctor, being asked about your suffering, having somebody write it down, taking a pill every morning, handed you by a person who expects you to get better. These trigger real dopamine and opioid pathways. You know, they release serotonin. Expectation is not imaginary.
但我们不能指责科学，因为科学有这种政治动机，要确保无论左派还是右派，你都认为这是我们研究这些事物的唯一方式。如果你不那样研究，你就不是一个严肃的人，尽管这在40年来让一切都变得更糟。看看这让你变成了什么样。与医生会面，被询问你的痛苦，让某人把它写下来，每天早上服用一颗由一个期望你康复的人递给你的药丸。这些触发了真实的多巴胺和阿片类通路。你知道，它们释放血清素。期望不是虚构的。
Ritual is not imaginary of going once a week to do something, even if it isn't perfect. It is chemistry. Add regression to the mean because people enter the trials at their absolute worst, and then the trial takes a long time to get on the calendar, and then the worst naturally passes, and then the natural passing gets booked as a placebo effect. Maybe the depression was just alive, and it was going up and down and doing this. It just wasn't a person with 15 depressions. It was depression as a living process. You know, add the psychiatric outcomes that are subjective reports and expectation shapes the report.
每周去做某事的仪式不是虚构的，即使它并不完美。它是化学反应。加上回归平均值，因为人们在最糟糕的状态下进入试验，然后试验在日程安排上需要很长时间，然后最糟糕的阶段自然过去，然后这种自然的消退被记录为安慰剂效应。也许抑郁症只是活的，它在起伏，在做这个动作。它不是一个有15种抑郁症的人。它是作为一种生命过程的抑郁症。你知道，加上那些主观报告的精神科结果，期望塑造了报告。
put it together and the placebo arm of the psychiatric trial is not an empty control. It's a package of active treatments, care, attention, ritual, hope, witnessing, a sort of shamanic person who's able to hear all this stuff and be bigger than it and hear it and understand it, but not be overwhelmed. It's a package of active treatment. And the architecture of the trial defines the whole package as zero. The field is, you know, quietly starting to admit this. But there is now a discipline called placebo studies.
把这些放在一起，精神科试验中的安慰剂组并不是一个空的对照。它是一套活跃的治疗方案：关怀、关注、仪式、希望、见证，一种能够听到所有这些东西并超越它、听到它、理解它但又不被它淹没的萨满式人物。这是一套活跃的治疗方案。而试验的架构将整个方案定义为零。这个领域，你知道，正在悄悄地开始承认这一点。但现在有一门学科叫安慰剂研究。
There's a program at Harvard, and they study nothing else. The strangest result in it is that there's something called open label placebo. You give people a pill, you tell them plainly that it is a placebo, and it still works measurably, and the ritual of care works with the curtain open. And at that point, the word placebo is just the name that we give the medicine that we refuse to take credit for. And so maybe noticing the mechanism of action that we can't admit, you know, the being seen, the naming, the knowing somebody is paying attention to your suffering on a schedule, that would explain why every real therapy works about equally well. It would explain why the placebo arm, you know, keeps performing at the same efficacy. It would explain why the drug arm barely beats the placebo effect for most drugs.
哈佛大学有一个项目，他们只研究这个。其中最奇怪的结果是有一种东西叫“开放标签安慰剂”。你给人们一颗药丸，明确告诉他们这是安慰剂，它仍然能产生可测量的效果，关怀的仪式在幕布拉开的情况下依然有效。在这一点上，“安慰剂”这个词只是我们给那些我们拒绝承认其功劳的药物所起的名字。所以，也许注意到我们无法承认的作用机制，你知道，被看见、被命名、知道有人按计划关注你的痛苦，这就能解释为什么每一种真正的疗法效果都差不多。它能解释为什么安慰剂组，你知道，一直保持着同样的疗效。它能解释为什么对于大多数药物来说，药物组几乎无法超过安慰剂效应。
And it is one hypothesis that the ritual can never test. because the ritual is built on subtracting exactly that. It found something that it couldn't see, and so it decided it didn't exist. The problem was never that the placebo effect contaminated psychiatric trials. The problem statement itself was wrong. The placebo effect is not in the way of medicine. It is most of the medicine, and we built 100 years of method around throwing it away, which reframes the whole hearing one last time.
这是一个仪式永远无法测试的假设。因为仪式建立在减去这些东西的基础上。它发现了一些它看不见的东西，于是它断定它不存在。问题从来不是安慰剂效应污染了精神科试验。问题陈述本身就是错的。安慰剂效应并没有阻碍医学。它本身就是医学的大部分，而我们围绕着扔掉它建立了一百年的方法，这让整个听证会重新定义了一次。
The FDA's objection was that the patients knew if they got better, not just the researchers. Only the researchers were supposed to know that they didn't have PTSD. In a mind, the knowing is the active ingredient and the connection is part of the cure. And this is why the series is called what it's called. Therapy was the study of the worm ghost, the living, moving, moving, relational thing, that cold machines worm ghost songs that was the theme of the psycho history series. It's a person, but a person is not something that is entirely tangible. It is its connections to other things. You know, the instruments were imported. They were built to measure that, this cold machine,
FDA的反对意见是，患者知道他们是否好转，不仅仅是研究人员知道。只有研究人员应该知道他们没有患创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）。在思想中，这种“知道”就是活性成分，而联系是治愈的一部分。这就是为什么这个系列叫这个名字。治疗是对“蠕虫幽灵”的研究，那种活着的、移动的、关系性的东西，那些冷冰冰的机器蠕虫幽灵之歌，那是心理历史系列的主题。它是一个人，但人不是完全有形的东西。它是它与其他事物的联系。你知道，这些仪器是进口的。它们是为了测量那个冷冰冰的机器而制造的，
but it could never really hold the ghost. And like, I don't know. physics is like the hardest science that there is. It met this problem at the bottom of matter and it gave up on the detached deserer. Like serious physicists will tell you that there is no view from nowhere because the looking is part of what you get. Once you observe something, it changes. And you can't go back and observe it twice from the same perspective at the same time. That you only get to touch it once. And so this whole idea of objectivity in physics,
但它永远无法真正抓住那个幽灵。就像，我不知道。物理学是现存最硬的科学。它在物质的最底层遇到了这个问题，并放弃了那种超然的观察者。严肃的物理学家会告诉你，不存在“无处之视角”，因为观察本身就是你所获得的一部分。一旦你观察某物，它就改变了。你无法回到过去，在同一时间从同一视角观察它两次。你只能触碰它一次。所以这种关于物理学客观性的整个想法，
is not real, which is, that's the heart of science to get humble. But it's one of the easiest sciences to get weird because they're not insecure about working with numbers. It's all they do. You know, psychology, which studies the most observer entangled thing in the universe, a person, you know, three feet away, bleeding their whole life into the air, went the other direction. It got stricter. It built the double bind. It climbed onto the throne that physics had just climbed down from. Michael Polani said, you know, we know more than we can tell. Everything explicit and measurable floats on this ocean of tacit knowledge.
是不真实的，这正是科学变得谦卑的核心。但它是最容易变得古怪的科学之一，因为他们不担心处理数字。这就是他们所做的一切。你知道，心理学，它研究的是宇宙中最纠缠观察者的东西——一个人，你知道，在三英尺外，把他们的一生都流露在空气中，却走向了另一个方向。它变得更严格了。它建立了双重束缚。它爬上了物理学刚刚爬下来的王座。迈克尔·波兰尼说，你知道，我们知道的比我们能说的多。一切显性的、可测量的东西都漂浮在这片默会知识的海洋上。
Common sense. What is self-evident? The felt sense. The thing that an experienced clinician knows the second you walk into the room, but they can't really explain why they know it, these sort of hunches about like, I think that you're talking about all these things, but really what we're talking about is you're afraid to be alone. What happens if you're alone? Let's go there.
常识。什么是自明的？那种感觉。一个经验丰富的临床医生在你走进房间的那一刻就知道的东西，但他们无法真正解释为什么知道，这些关于“我想你在谈论所有这些事情，但实际上我们谈论的是你害怕孤独”的直觉。如果你孤独会发生什么？让我们去探讨那个。
What would you feel if I told you couldn't leave this office? And I'm going to walk out that door and you're going to have to sit on the couch. What do you feel? All of a sudden, the person feels uncomfortable. I can't tell you how I get there with a client. I just know that it works and I know that I know it. When the ritual throws out the clinical judgment and the common sense and the self-evident, it's not being stricter and it's not being more logical.
如果我告诉你不能离开这间办公室，你会感觉如何？我要走出那扇门，你必须坐在沙发上。你感觉到了什么？突然间，那个人感到不舒服。我无法告诉你我是如何与客户达到那种程度的。我只是知道它有效，而且我知道我知道它。当仪式抛弃了临床判断、常识和自明之理时，它并没有变得更严格，也没有变得更合乎逻辑。
It's being more stupid and it will become more insane. And it will build systems around it that reflect that insanity. You know, it kept the lit, tip and it sawed off the iceberg. Because it could measure the tip of the iceberg, but it couldn't see the thing holding that up. That doesn't make it not real. Now the tip's going to sink.
它变得更愚蠢了，而且它会变得更疯狂。它会围绕它建立反映这种疯狂的系统。你知道，它保留了冰山一角，却锯掉了冰山主体。因为它能测量冰山一角，但它看不见支撑它的东西。这并不代表它不存在。现在冰山一角要沉下去了。
Knowledge didn't grow. It shrank to what a trial can hold, which is a thimble because you can't, like Pawani's saying, you can't really tell somebody everything you know. You're a professional and you do this for a living and you're good at it, and they just kind of have to know that you know what you're doing. There's not a bureaucracy that can justify, you know, like all of this stuff.
知识并没有增长。它萎缩到了试验所能容纳的程度，也就是一个顶针的大小，因为你不能，就像波兰尼所说的，你不能真正告诉别人你知道的一切。你是一个专业人士，你以此为生，你很擅长，他们只能相信你知道自己在做什么。没有一个官僚机构能证明，你知道，所有这些东西。
So, like, these systems are dumber than any one person inside of them. They're dumber than you, they're dumber than me, and I'm not a smart guy, again. Like, this stuff's just not that hard. It's just that nobody looks at it. Nobody reads it. I don't have an intellectual gift. I have an emotional gift of, like, not caring about looking at things that are horrifying, like the way that our world is run.
所以，这些系统比其中的任何一个人都要愚蠢。它们比你蠢，比我蠢，而且我再说一遍，我不是个聪明人。这些东西真的没那么难。只是没人去看它。没人读它。我没有什么智力天赋。我有一种情感天赋，就是不在乎去审视那些令人恐惧的事情，比如我们这个世界是如何运作的。
And, you know, because almost nobody understands how the gears actually turn, the few people who do can run the rest of us through them to make money, to launder and lie into, to launder this lie, like into a fact. And that only works while most people cannot see the gears. It stops the moment that enough people can. And that's the reason why I make these. You know, three things can happen to a real discovery inside the system. One, it gets co-opted and packaged and sold back to you.
而且，你知道，因为几乎没有人理解齿轮实际上是如何转动的，少数理解的人可以把我们其余的人通过这些齿轮碾压，来赚钱，来洗钱，把这个谎言洗成事实。而这只有在大多数人看不见齿轮时才有效。一旦足够多的人能看见，它就停止了。这就是我制作这些节目的原因。你知道，一个真正的发现在系统内部会发生三件事。第一，它被收编、包装并卖回给你。
Two, it gets ignored, left in a drawer because it does not fit the forms. Or the discoverer gets pushed out. He's not part of the system anymore. Those are your choices if you don't want to play by these rules. And a therapist has names for those. Swallowing a threat hole so it can't attack you from the outside is interjection. You know, it's the thing that exists, the cabinet that exists that never gets open. That's denial.
第二，它被忽视，扔在抽屉里，因为它不符合表格。或者发现者被排挤出去。他不再是系统的一部分了。如果你不想按这些规则玩，这就是你的选择。而治疗师对这些有专门的名称。把威胁整个吞下，让它不能从外部攻击你，这就是内摄。你知道，那个存在但从不被打开的柜子。那是否认。
You're splitting off a part of you. that knows and then treating it as an enemy inside of you because it knows that the thing that I need to believe is true is not actually true. That's dissociation. And we are moving in to an epic of dissociation as a nation. Those are all defenses. Nobody in the institution decided on them. Nobody wrote them down. They formed automatically in response to a threat that the system could not afford to feel exactly the way that they form in an individual. They have formed in the soft sciences of American political sciences. And I don't just mean political science. Economics is political science. Psychology is a political science. Sociology is a political science. Marine biology is
你分裂出你的一部分，那部分知道真相，然后把它当作你内部的敌人来对待，因为它知道我需要相信的东西实际上并不是真的。那是解离。我们作为一个国家正在进入一个解离的时代。这些都是防御机制。机构里没有人决定使用它们。没有人把它们写下来。它们是作为对系统无法承受的威胁的自动反应而形成的，就像它们在个人身上形成的方式一样。它们已经在美式政治科学的软科学中形成了。我指的不仅仅是政治学。经济学是政治科学。心理学是政治科学。社会学是政治科学。海洋生物学则
not. So it's allowed to agree on what its purpose is because they know that they study whales. Psychologists are kind of confused about what knowledge is or humanity or the purpose of the study that they're doing. An institution has an unconscious. It has material that it cannot lay. let into awareness. It has protector parts. You know, that fire before anyone in the building finishes the thought. And the defining feature of every defended psyche that I've ever sat with as a therapist is that it experiences the cure as the attack. You have to push people into the shadow. You have to push people into the thing that they think is bad that is inside of them because the things inside of them are not all bad. You know, a patient gets one sentence away
不是。所以它被允许就其目的达成一致，因为他们知道他们研究的是鲸鱼。心理学家对什么是知识、什么是人性或他们正在进行的研究的目的感到困惑。一个机构有潜意识。它有无法进入意识的材料。它有保护部分。你知道，在任何人完成思考之前就开火。而我作为治疗师所接触过的每一个有防御心理的人，其定义特征就是它将治愈体验为攻击。你必须把人们推向阴影。你必须把人们推向他们认为在他们内心深处是坏的东西，因为他们内心的东西并不全是坏的。你知道，一个病人离真相只有一句话的距离，
from the true thing. And the whole personality reorganizes it's in a half second. So that the sentence never lands. And the patient's not lying. The patient's not even present for the operation. A committee gets handed, you know, the best PTSD result ever recorded. And the result threatens the ritual that the committee is tasked with doing. And so the committee reorganizes. There's not a villain and there's not stupid people in that room.
而整个人格在半秒钟内就重组了。所以那句话永远不会落地。病人并没有撒谎。病人甚至没有参与这次操作。一个委员会被交给了，你知道，有史以来记录的最好的PTSD结果。而这个结果威胁到了委员会被指派执行的仪式。于是委员会重组了。那个房间里没有恶棍，也没有愚蠢的人。
They're smarter than me. Every person in the chain can privately see that it's absurd. But it happens anyway because the system is not the sum of the people. It is the rules. It's not people anymore. It's bureaucracy. And that is why I made the psycho history series. Psychology is the eye that America uses to look at itself.
他们比我聪明。链条上的每个人私下里都能看出这是荒谬的。但它还是发生了，因为系统不是人的总和。它是规则。它不再是人了。它是官僚主义。这就是我制作心理历史系列的原因。心理学是美国用来审视自己的眼睛。
And the eye has blind spots. And the blind spots have a history. And the cycles run through the country's metabolism and surpluses come in and national ego inflates. And the psychology of the era turns grandiose and human potential and the conquest of inner space. And then the surplus goes out and the ego deflates. and psychology turns into coping and risk and deficiency and medication. But it is packaging all of those things as science that doesn't know what it is anymore. Because the mind of the empire tracks the material life of the empire.
而这只眼睛有盲点。盲点有历史。周期在国家的代谢中运行，盈余进来，国家自尊膨胀。那个时代的心理学变得宏大，关注人类潜能和对内心空间的征服。然后盈余流出，自尊萎缩，心理学变成了应对、风险、缺陷和药物。但它把所有这些东西包装成不再知道自己是什么的科学。因为帝国的思想追踪着帝国的物质生活。
And as a Jungian leaning therapist, I'm not a certified analyst, but I like Jung a lot, Carl Jung. I'm, you know, a lot of people think because I like mythology or I study mythology or history or some of these things, that I like, you come in and you say, I'm, I'm just a wounded healer who's a therapist and I'm like, oh, I need to tell you the myth of the wounded healer. I need to tell you the myth of Perseus or your ego's inflating. Let me tell you the myth of the guy that flies too close to the sun. No, that's not what it's about. It's about demythologizing the self. It's about understanding mythology, not to mythologize the self more to make yourself a part of it or to see yourself in the cycles of it.
作为一个倾向于荣格学派的治疗师，我不是认证分析师，但我很喜欢荣格，卡尔·荣格。我，你知道，很多人认为因为我喜欢神话，或者我研究神话或历史或其中一些东西，我就像，你进来然后你说，我只是一个受伤的治疗师，然后我就说，哦，我需要告诉你受伤治疗师的神话。我需要告诉你珀尔修斯的神话，或者你的自尊在膨胀。让我告诉你那个飞得离太阳太近的家伙的神话。不，那不是重点。重点是去神话化自我。重点是理解神话，不是为了更多地神话化自我，而是为了让自己成为它的一部分，或者在它的周期中看到自己。
Some analysts only do that. I disagree. It's about realizing how these myths function and how timeless they are so that we can take them off and be free of them as an individual and as a nation. I don't know. I was watching The Odyssey with my family and it was really interesting. I really liked it. I don't love everything about Christopher Nolan, but I do think his movies are incredible. I just think he can't write dialogue and he can't shoot action.
有些分析师只做前者。我不同意。重点是意识到这些神话是如何运作的，以及它们是多么永恒，这样我们就可以脱下它们，作为一个个人和一个国家从它们中解放出来。我不知道。我和家人在看《奥德赛》，这真的很有趣。我真的很喜欢它。我并不喜欢克里斯托弗·诺兰的一切，但我确实认为他的电影令人难以置信。我只是觉得他写不好对话，也拍不好动作戏。
And then a lot of times, even though he can't write dialogue great, he writes tone and theme perfectly. and that's kind of why people like him. You know, he decides what a movie is about and what its theme is, and then it's tonally and thematically consistent, even when the dialogue can't really contain the themes he's trying to do. And the Odyssey is about the end of empire.
而且很多时候，尽管他写不好对话，但他把基调和主题写得非常完美。这就是人们喜欢他的原因。你知道，他决定了一部电影是关于什么的，它的主题是什么，然后它在基调和主题上是一致的，即使对话无法真正承载他试图表达的主题。而《奥德赛》是关于帝国的终结。
It's about the fall of these people at the end of the Bronze Age. And I don't just mean the book. I mean, like Christopher Nolan's movie. But it's the end of this world. And Nolan's, you know, always talking in that movie, spoiler for a 2,000-year-old play, sorry,
它是关于青铜时代末期这些人的陨落。我指的不仅仅是书。我指的是，比如克里斯托弗·诺兰的电影。但这是这个世界的终结。而诺兰的，你知道，在那部电影里总是谈论，剧透一个2000年前的剧本，抱歉，
about the, he kind of, there's a, there's a guest host relationship in Greece that is really important. And he calls it the law of Zeus in the movie, but that's kind of an oversimplification. If you ask what the law of Zeus was to an ancient Greek, they'd be like,
关于，他有点，有一种在希腊非常重要的客主关系。他在电影里称之为宙斯法则，但这有点过于简化了。如果你问一个古希腊人宙斯法则是什么，他们会说，
well, there's a lot of them. And also none of them, because he's kind of not, anyway, but the, the idea is that, there's this like, you know, trick that they do to make the Trojan War happen to have the Trojan horse.
嗯，有很多，而且也都没有，因为他有点不是，总之，但这个想法是，有这种，你知道，他们为了让特洛伊战争发生而使用的诡计，为了有特洛伊木马。
Everybody knows the story. I'm not going to summarize the Odyssey for you. I'm sorry, I started to do that. And then my eyes are glazing over. But there's this idea that there are these laws that hold the world together that can't really be enforced externally. We have to enforce them internally. And when you get rid of those, your culture doesn't really work anymore. And he's making a lot of this movie about, and the honesty was about the end of the Bronze Age.
每个人都知道这个故事。我不会为你总结《奥德赛》。抱歉，我开始那样做了。然后我的眼睛开始发直。但有这样一个想法，即有一些法律将世界维系在一起，这些法律无法真正从外部强制执行。我们必须在内部强制执行它们。当你摆脱了这些，你的文化就不再真正运作了。而他把这部电影的很多内容，以及《奥德赛》都是关于青铜时代的终结。
I mean, it was about there, you know, there was a city that was like close to Turkey that it wasn't one city probably, but it was a bunch of walled cities and they controlled trade. And then the Greeks got angry and then there's droughts for a long time. And you have all these people, you know, coming in to the Hittite empire and all these empires and they're like pulling them apart. And those IMAX projectors that Nolan uses, those things are like insane. Like the reason that nobody shoots on IMAX anymore is because it was this thing that like one was invented to solve a problem that they had at the Colombian exposition for the World's Fair in 1907 where you had like a whole bunch of 35 millimeter projectors. And they tried to make them overlap, but it doesn't really work because there's like too much light bleed. and so they're like, what if you had a huge piece of film? And somebody tried to make this giant, you know, 70 millimeter film played,
我的意思是，它是关于那里，你知道，有一个城市靠近土耳其，可能不是一个城市，而是一堆围墙城市，他们控制着贸易。然后希腊人愤怒了，然后有很长一段时间的干旱。你有所有这些人，你知道，进入赫梯帝国和所有这些帝国，他们把它们撕裂了。而诺兰使用的那些IMAX放映机，那些东西简直疯狂。就像没人再用IMAX拍摄的原因是因为它是一个，你知道，最初是为了解决他们在1907年世界博览会上遇到的问题，当时你有好几台35毫米放映机。他们试图让它们重叠，但这并不真正奏效，因为光线溢出太多。所以他们想，如果你有一大块胶片会怎样？有人试图制作这种巨大的，你知道，70毫米胶片盘，
but you can't move film that fast because when you move it that fast, it starts to ripple like it goes like this. Eventually it'll tear itself apart. But the image that it's projecting is not flat anymore. So it defeats the purpose of film. And so the way they solved that problem with this like huge ass piece of film is that they built tiny vacuum, like, you know, apertures all around it that sucked the film flat so that it
但你不能移动胶片那么快，因为当你移动得那么快时，它开始起波纹，就像这样。最终它会把自己撕裂。但它投射的图像不再是平的了。所以它违背了胶片的初衷。所以他们用这种巨大的胶片解决这个问题的方法是，他们建造了微小的真空，就像，你知道，周围的孔径，把胶片吸平，这样它
couldn't ripple, which means you have to build a vacuum, not only into your projector, but also into your camera, but then in order to get light through that thing, to get the dynamic range that you need and get at the distance that you have to have, you have to have a xenon bulb that is so bright. There are some modern alternatives now, but up until the 80s, they still had these. And some of the new ones still do because they didn't make them anymore. It would burn the celluloid film on fire. So you had to have a plate of water that was constantly circulating, like a water-cooled
就不会起波纹，这意味着你不仅要在放映机里建立真空，还要在摄像机里建立真空，但为了让光线穿过那个东西，为了获得你需要的动态范围，并达到你必须有的距离，你必须有一个非常亮的氙气灯泡。现在有一些现代替代品，但在80年代之前，他们仍然有这些。有些新的仍然有，因为他们不再制造它们了。它会把赛璐珞胶片烧着。所以你必须有一个不断循环的水盘，就像水冷
PC pumping water across the plate to cool off this enormously hot bulb and then four vacuums sucking the film flat and then the plates of film are huge what you got to ship this thing like the little science documentaries they did were like you know 20 30 minutes long so they were shorter no one has a three hour film so to print these things it's a plate of film that's larger than a car and costs just to make the print then you got to ship it which is two to five thousand and careful it then bring it back and store it just to print the movie for one movie theater to have for one month it's 35 000 film they're insane and when iMac's trying to make these movies the CEO and all the people were like we don't have these anymore and nolan is kind of trying to go to the industry he's
PC泵水穿过盘子来冷却这个极其炽热的灯泡，然后四个真空吸盘把胶片吸平，然后胶片盘很大，你得运输这个东西，就像他们做的那些小科学纪录片，你知道，20到30分钟长，所以它们更短，没人有三小时的电影，所以要打印这些东西，这是一个比汽车还大的胶片盘，光是制作拷贝就花钱，然后你还得运输它，那是两到五千，小心它，然后带回来并储存它，仅仅是为了给一家电影院放映一个月，就是35000美元的胶片，它们太疯狂了。当IMAX试图制作这些电影时，CEO和所有人都说我们没有这些了，而诺兰有点试图去行业，他是
another director like tarantino that's angry that they don't shoot on film anymore and he's like you know this movie's huge it's selling out and you're making all the this money and you've been saying like, oh, digital and AI and all this stuff and people don't go to theaters anymore. They just want to watch on iPads. How do we get people to go back to theaters? I'm giving it to you and you won't do it. And the CEO says we can't. We don't have the technology to make these. We don't have the supply chains to make these. This thing that when I was a kid, I took for granted. I went in and I watched the fish movie at the Denver IMAX, you know, for $12 in 1987. And then, you know, when I watched a ton of them, like 1995, when they opened the, um, Birmingham one, like I saw a ton there.
另一个像昆汀一样的导演，对他们不再用胶片拍摄感到愤怒，他说，你知道这部电影很大，它卖光了，你赚了所有这些钱，你一直在说，哦，数字和人工智能和所有这些东西，人们不再去电影院了。他们只想在iPad上看。我们怎么让人们回到电影院？我把它给你，而你却不去做。CEO说我们不能。我们没有技术来制造这些。我们没有供应链来制造这些。这个东西，当我还是个孩子的时候，我认为是理所当然的。我进去，在丹佛IMAX看了那部鱼的电影，你知道，1987年花了12美元。然后，你知道，当我看了很多，比如1995年，当他们开了伯明翰那个，我在那里看了很多。
These giant machines that we take for granted, even though we've come so far and we have this progress and we have all this new science understanding, we can't do it anymore. We just won't. And I, all of that is baked into this weird meta metaphor around, um, or English majors don't come at me. I mean extended metaphor. Sorry. I like metametereter before, though. Um, about how. Christopher Nolan is thinking about this movie and what he's doing because he really is saying this is the end of the Bronze Age at a time where I think that I'm living at the end of the world and we know the things that can save us we know the rules that we should remember and everyone can see it and everybody knows but it's it's going away everyone who in the Odysseus even says it's very on the nose at the end of the film everybody who is going to write is about to die
这些我们认为是理所当然的巨大机器，尽管我们已经走了这么远，我们有了这种进步，我们有了所有这些新的科学理解，我们再也做不到了。我们只是不会。而我，所有这些都融入了这个围绕着，嗯，英语专业的别来找我。我的意思是扩展隐喻。抱歉。我喜欢元隐喻。嗯，关于克里斯托弗·诺兰是如何思考这部电影以及他正在做什么，因为他确实是在说这是青铜时代的终结，在一个我认为我生活在世界末日的时代，我们知道能拯救我们的东西，我们知道我们应该记住的规则，每个人都能看到，每个人都知道，但它正在消失，每个人在《奥德赛》中甚至说，在电影结尾非常直白，每一个要写的人都要死了
And so if my story gets preserved at all, it will be through people singing it because they're not going to forget how to sing. You know, the industry knows what it needs to build and it won't do it. It won't start the supply lines. It has to keep going along the rules that it's made. And I don't want to stretch the metaphor too much about projectors, even though if I talk about things that are interesting to me long enough, eventually I've noticed that they all kind of come together and my brain will just do that and I have to have faith that it will land the plane. but the next episode is going to be about oil. And it will be part two of this one. You know, this series is about how everyone who looks at this industry,
所以如果我的故事能被保存下来，那将是通过人们歌唱它，因为他们不会忘记如何歌唱。你知道，行业知道它需要建立什么，但它不会去做。它不会启动供应链。它必须继续沿着它制定的规则走。我不想过多地延伸关于放映机的隐喻，尽管如果我谈论我感兴趣的事情足够久，最终我注意到它们都会汇聚在一起，我的大脑就会那样做，我必须相信它会平稳着陆。但下一集将是关于石油的。这将是这一集的第二部分。你知道，这个系列是关于每一个审视这个行业的人，
many industries, at Empire, at the micro, at the macro right now, they know what they need. And we know the building the world that could save us. We know what it would require and we know it's possible. But culturally, we can't do those things. anymore. And that's a pathology. That's a problem. You know, admitting that you need to rebuild your means of admitting and you're letting the capability to admit things to yourself that you know are true so that you can solve them as problems is something that you no longer can do and so you
许多行业，审视帝国，审视微观，审视宏观，现在，他们知道他们需要什么。我们知道建立那个能拯救我们的世界。我们知道它需要什么，我们也知道它是可能的。但在文化上，我们再也做不到那些事情了。那是一种病理。那是一个问题。你知道，承认你需要重建你的承认手段，而你正在失去对自己承认你知道是真实的事情的能力，以便你可以把它们作为问题来解决，这是你不再能做到的事情，所以你
have to dissociate. I think that's why people much, much, much smarter than me did everything that I just said in the beginning of this thing. You know, admitting that kept hack. the capability died means that you are admitting that you're not the country that can build things anymore. And so all of a sudden, this belief that it can't be done wins. And that's bad. I think your only choice there, you're probably your best choice is to dissociate a little bit, which is what people are doing now. And that's why Christopher Nolan is making a movie, I think, about the late Bronze Age collapse, you know, how linear B was going to vanish.
必须解离。我认为这就是为什么比我聪明得多得多得多的人做了我在这一开始所说的一切。你知道，承认那种能力已经死亡意味着你承认你不再是那个能制造东西的国家了。所以突然之间，这种“做不到”的信念赢了。这很糟糕。我认为你唯一的选择，你可能最好的选择是稍微解离一下，这就是人们现在正在做的。这就是为什么我认为克里斯托弗·诺兰正在制作一部关于晚期青铜时代崩溃的电影，你知道，线性文字B是如何消失的。
And I will follow up with this in part two sometime, hopefully, this week. Thanks for listening. This is Taproot. If you want to check out our website, get Therapy Birmingham.com, that'd be great. There's a lot of things on our blog, a lot of free resources. And if you would like to use the code Taproot at hardy.com, at gethardy.com. There are a micronutrition company that we work with, and I do get a kickback from if you use our code, which is hugely helpful to give me the motivation to continue to make
我会在第二部分跟进这个，希望在本周。感谢收听。这是Taproot。如果你想看看我们的网站，gettherapybirmingham.com，那太好了。我们的博客上有很多东西，很多免费资源。如果你想在hardy.com，gethardy.com使用代码Taproot。他们是一家我们合作的微量营养素公司，如果你使用我们的代码，我会得到回扣，这对我继续制作非常有帮助
this show because there's a lot of expenses associated with it, mainly time. I do enjoy doing it, but it's always the last thing that I'm going to get to since it is kind of a money sync right now. But Hardy was a company that I started working with because I heard from a lot of patients that it was super helpful. I heard from a couple other therapists and I looked up their site and, you know, because randomized controlled trials can study micronutrients, there was all this research. And they'd paid for randomized controlled trials on their product. And their research was really good. They even took Canada, which has extremely strict evidence-based practice laws to court. They took the Supreme Court of Canada to court and they said, we have really strong research. We get to say that we can
这个节目，因为这有很多相关费用，主要是时间。我确实喜欢做这件事，但它总是最后才轮到我做，因为它现在有点像个无底洞。但Hardy是我开始合作的一家公司，因为我从很多病人那里听说它非常有帮助。我从其他几个治疗师那里也听说了，我查了他们的网站，你知道，因为随机对照试验可以研究微量营养素，所以有所有的研究。他们为他们的产品支付了随机对照试验的费用。他们的研究真的很好。他们甚至把加拿大，那个有极其严格的循证实践法律的国家，告上了法庭。他们把加拿大最高法院告上了法庭，他们说，我们有非常强大的研究。我们有权说我们可以
treat ADHD and symptoms of autism and children. And Canada has to let them do that. It's printed on the bottle. And I was just interviewing them because I like having podcasts on and it was cool. And then they sent me some of the stuff. And I wasn't treating anything. I mean, I took G&C vitamins before, which are not, you know, bad vitamins. I don't think.
治疗儿童的ADHD和自闭症症状。而加拿大必须让他们这样做。它印在瓶子上。我当时只是在采访他们，因为我喜欢做播客，这很酷。然后他们寄给我一些东西。我并没有在治疗任何东西。我的意思是，我以前吃过GNC维生素，它们不是，你知道，坏维生素。我不这么认为。
Or at least they are expensive. And I took Hardy and I immediately felt a lot better just because I got it for free in the mail. And my wife made fun of me and was like, you're going to be Alex Jones selling these on the radio. And then she started taking them and she really liked them. So that's the randomized controlled trial. I ran in my own house, which I did not control for the placebo effect for. And I think they're good. So if you want to support the show, that'd be a huge help.
或者至少它们很贵。我吃了Hardy，我立刻感觉好多了，只是因为我免费收到了它。我妻子取笑我，说你就像亚历克斯·琼斯在广播里卖这些东西一样。然后她开始吃它们，她真的很喜欢它们。所以这就是我在自己家里进行的随机对照试验，我没有控制安慰剂效应。我认为它们很好。所以如果你想支持这个节目，那将是一个巨大的帮助。
We also have a store that has some cool swag and merch. We sell that at cost. But if you're just looking for, you know, one of the cool saying about Carl Jung, like one of the eat your shadow shirts or the white on white, you know, taproot embroidery that we're getting out for fall, the sweatshirt. Check it out. I think they're neat. And I will see you sometime later this week. Thanks for listening. Now tonight's the night when the waters rise, you'll grope in in the dark. And ticket takers count the men can afford the arc. The ticket takers will not board. The ticket takers are tied. For five and change an hour.
我们还有一个商店，有一些很酷的周边和商品。我们按成本价出售。但如果你只是在寻找，你知道，关于卡尔·荣格的酷话，比如“吃掉你的阴影”衬衫，或者我们为秋季推出的白色刺绣Taproot卫衣。去看看吧。我认为它们很整洁。我会在本周晚些时候见到你。感谢收听。现在今晚是水位上涨的时候，你会在黑暗中摸索。而售票员计算着能负担得起方舟的人。售票员不会登船。售票员被绑住了。每小时五块多一点。
to count the passers by. Now they say the sky's the limit, though the sky's about to fall. Down come all them record books, cradle and all. They say before he bid it that the boxer filled no pain, but somewhere there's a gambling man
去数过路人。现在他们说天空是极限，尽管天空即将塌陷。所有的记录簿都倒下来了，摇篮和一切。他们说在他出价之前，拳击手没有感到痛苦，但在某个地方有一个赌徒
with a ticket in the rain. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
拿着一张雨中的票。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。